Kimball Walker has helped this team to
kind of turn the tide three on the money
for a lookout this is all Lucca and it's
not an easy step back whatever happens
he just continues to point will step
back action he's missed that shot a
couple of times tonight but still with
the same confidence in the same wheel to
draw to play that's one of his favorite
moves to that little step-back
of jail entire career with the Los
Angeles Clippers there's that stick back
three pointer doors well just a little
up fake and that is his patented move
that buried the boundaries because
there's been a lot of the tips of two of
collectively that's just step back three
Luca
[Applause]
music look at step-back three nine
nothing doubtless rough are you Cynthia
stiff defense going back he steps back
and makes them pay mattresses down to
right now
second look Luka get that done again
challenge coming up at half-time
I'll be serious that's right history
ditch drains are three coming out of the
timeout play away the veils double
double his first since March of 2017 as
Dodger hits it from way downtown there
is reason that he didn't play college
basketball and still got drafted
Mitchell Robinson Newton with an answer
at the other end as collagen the
province who dollars can't get stops
you go on the bounce shot bacon lots of
dry hits
sitting inside one of his favorite shots
to step for their outfits and just
really spotted the game with the right
intensity on the defensive end of the
floor let's see how they close out the
first half
Burks makes the free throw he's top five
and free throw percentage at over 90 for
us okay and on to Jeff right on cue nine
ten and three now that I've heard some
fans say Oh only make free throws we
were warned a couple games the
difference between you know a 70%
shooting in a 76% she's probably not
gonna win or lose a game unless you're
up by one or two well a lot of dummies
like me then saw dork very early in his
career Bob what was Dallas
[Music]
what they were thinking was they had a
future hall-of-famer late clock
situation here for Lucca and a step back
over
back three-ball how's this well when you
back off and that's what Rubio was doing
just forcing them to kind of take that
shot
on suits just shoot da itch against
Anderson step back gun puts it in
he planted Real Madrid which is a really
good proving ground for young players to
develop again from the corner and again
he may pass caught by Luca upon him is
heartless big screen set by Jordan pain
yes sir that's too Smith driving it on
Lillard then it's got 5,000 Smith's left
he paddled Luca look
[Applause]
great step back three Smith lost his
footing and then here's Luca Harvey this
tremendous ability to stay on balance
after stepping back to have the strength
to get that shot up that's not
necessarily an easy shot it's just a
great offensive play
[Music]
Lucca averages seven pull-up jump shots
per game and shoots 41% now that may not
sound like a lot
pardon missed one that's the state of
affairs in the last 30 seconds when
Houston having an eight-point lead in
cut to five and now dr. Terry the first
three from moved he gets a big on it
steps back on compellable screen by
DeAndre capella switched on to Luka
and then one more row do you say if you
don't know now you know taught at no.1
right now average second book back to
back Don Cheech a little step back three
that's what he does
you're gonna see this right here look at
this step that is such a hard move on
everybody to link back to Luke who was
seven now on the shot clock
watch thought of it jump on him in the
corner the first shot Luke and choose
him to put it on the dead eight points
they need something really special out
of him again tonight
he works against cauley-stein
be the beginning in something special
not just picked up by yogic Nanshan
steps back let's go get some good rains
didn't he God allow he got picked off
gotcha
oh nice step back ten five hits the fray
Luka darkish Xander tried they tried to
steal it but picked up the foul look at
the thrust on that step back because he
actually penetrates takes